Cornell's comprehensive assessment of
soil health goes beyond just testing
soil nutrient levels but like any soil
testing the information it provides
depends on how well you sample the soil
as well as asking the right questions
before sampling
although the Cornell soil health lab
accepts samples year-round the best time
to take soil samples is in the spring
you should take your samples when the
soil is workable and neither too wet nor
too dry
a good rule of thumb is if the field can
be plowed it is probably a good time to
sample how you sample will depend on
what questions are trying to answer if
you're trying to assess soil health for
an entire field or management unit with
similar soils in management history walk
through the entire field making a path
that looks like a big W taking sub
samples at five to ten spots avoid areas
that are not representative of your
entire sampling area or if you're trying
to identify soil constraints for trouble
spots in the field make your path just
through the identified weak part of the
field sample this problem area as a
separate labelled sample it is also
useful to take a sample from outside of
your management area to help quantify
the effects of your management
so I've identified that this spot is a
good representation of our field so the
first step is to remove the debris you
don't need to dig that deep of a hole
you're looking for about 8 inches the
soil is basically perfect for taking a
soil sample it might be slightly on the
wet side but in the spring you got to
kind of take it when you have a chance
and this is our chance so I'm removing
the soil I set it to the side so that I
can put it back in the hole so we don't
have any holes the tractor might have
problems with all right so I've got
about an 8 inch hole and now I'm going
to take what we call a slice of bread
from the edge of the hole we're looking
for about 2 inches thick by about the
shovel wide and 6 inches deep
all right we pull it up
it's about perfectly six inches deep but
now we're looking for the soil to be
consider or we want to have consistent
amounts of soil from the top layer down
to the six inch mark so I'm removing any
extra soil from the side we're looking
for that nice even layer a little
thicker at the bottom it's gonna even it
out a bit
looks pretty good it's about six inches
and then it goes in the bucket it's a
sample one and then from there we can
move on and take the other samples
you will want to take a pen at trauma
two reading at each spot that you're
sampling across the W shaped pattern so
you're going to be looking at the zero
to six inch mark and also zero to 18 and
you're going to be watching the inter
gauge on the penetrator and making a
mental note of what the highest psi you
reaches so first we're going to go down
to the 6 inch there's this mark down
here that shows us the six inch and the
18th is a little bit higher so I'm not
feeling too much compaction I'm keeping
an eye on the six inch mark that hit
about 150 psi
make a mental note of that and then you
continue to the 18 inch mark I start to
feel more compaction
I'm surpassing 300 psi there's the plow
pan and you got to push a little bit
farther to get to that 18 that hit about
400 psi I've made a mental note of how
much compaction I recorded with the pen
at Ramat er and I'm going to go ahead
and take the back of the submission form
in this case this is location 1 so 0 to
6 was 150 and 6 to 18 was 400 alright
and then we're ready to move to our next
location now that I've taken 10 sub
samples across the field in a w-shaped
pattern I will mix the sample extremely
well at the same time I'm pulling any
plant matter out to make sure that we
have an accurate sample to send to the
lab now I have this well mixed soil
there's no clods everything is broken up
really well the soil is a really nice
consistency for sampling see how the
aggregates just sort of crumble apart
showing we have good structure probably
good microbial activity and then I go
ahead and I take my labeled ziplock bag
I have my submission form right here
which I use I've already filled out the
front of this I mean I know I'm in field
II
and I go ahead and start taking samples
out of this so the way that we typically
do it and our research plots kind of
like take a handful don't really worry
about sort of spilling some toss them
out of there I'm avoiding any debris and
I'm looking for about six cups because
I'm taking this for the extended package
if I was taking it for the basic package
that requires three cups that's about
three cups and then if I'm going for the
standard I'm looking for about four cups
it's about what that looks like maybe a
little more
that'd probably be nice first standard
but in this case we're doing the
extended so we're looking for six cups
of soil all right that's a little more
than six cups right there so we're
looking for looks great
go ahead close your bag and you're ready
to move on to your next field after
you've collected all of your sub samples
mix them well put them into a bag you're
going to go ahead and just make a note
of your GPS coordinates you should use
whatever program works best for you and
you don't need to record each section
each one of your sub samples if you want
to that's great of course but generally
I would just record the field
send your soil samples via the United
States Post Office rapid shipping and
remember to include a submission form
with a blue ice pack in a labeled
ziplock bag
note an ice pack is only necessary in
the hot months and is not needed if the
weather is cool and you use rapid
shipping please refer to our website for
more detailed instructions on taking a
soil sample including a field guide for
soil sampling and more information on
soil health in general